Welcome the founder of The Honest Company, Jessica Alba!
(audience applauding)
Hi.
(applauding continues)
Are we allowed to?
We're not allowed to,
isn't that horrible?
Oh no.
I know, I love you so much.
I'm so... (inhales)
(exhales) I'm so happy for you.
Thank you.
My friend, this extraordinary woman who changed the world,
you IPO'd for Honest Company yesterday.
I saw you ringing the bell
with your beautiful child in your arms.
Your company is going to be estimated at about $1.4 billion.
(audience applauds)
(Jessica chuckles)
I mean, when you were little,
did you ever see this happening?
No, I mean, this is like,
I had this idea to create this company
because it just made sense
that people shouldn't have to choose
between what works and what's good for them.
And putting people's health and wellness,
and thinking about the planet and sustainability,
and then also like diversity and inclusion
and representation, and all of those values,
to me is really I think,
why we've been able to take the business to this point.
And also the connection with charity and Baby2Baby
and giving back, which you're also part of.
So, I feel like this is the beginning of our next chapter.
With my kids and my husband, it's been such a journey
getting to this point and I'm just thrilled.
And I hope that when our kids, when our girls are grown,
that there's a lot more of people that look like us,
that are in this position
because we're still so underrepresented
in all of business, in government,
and all these different ways.
So I hope that by me being here,
it's like a little tiny step forward, and we can chip away.
By you being here, chip away, right?
And so let's do our part in just making sure I think,
and just making it easier for everyone
to be represented in every sector.
I'm really excited that we got to this point.
I just can't believe!
(Jessica laughs)
I'm so happy.
And by the way, I am also--
Just remember "Never Been Kissed."
Wait, no.
(Jessica laughs)
Okay, wait, look, I pulled up some pictures for us.
There we go.
Yup.
I mean, that was us
(Jessica laughs)
back in the day.
(Jessica laughing)
It's a true story.
I mean, (mumbles)
It's wild, it's so wild.
And you believed in me
when I was just a scrappy little nugget
(audience laughs)
just trying to like, get a job.
I have another picture pulled up
where I'm with you at a Baby2Baby event.
I'm pregnant with my second daughter, Frankie in that.
And I have looked to you as an example,
honestly, as a mom and a friend,
what you guys do with Baby2Baby,
and I'm just so passionate about what you do.
You give back so much.
You set the tone for how we're supposed to be.
Now all of my cleaning products
are in your sustainable bottles and--
Actually, a lot of my sustainability
or the values around sustainability come from my grandma,
just to bring it back around to why we're here today
and paying homage to our family and our family members.
But my grandma, she would re-use and recycle everything.
Really?
Every margarine tub,
that was our Tupperware.
We didn't go and buy extra stuff.
She would MacGyver everything,
everything had five different uses.
And so I take that sensibility when I was building Honest.
You know, you pull a lot from your own life experience
and then up-cycling, recycling, reusing,
that's just embedded in who I am as a person.
I hate wasting things, you know?
That's exactly why you went
on that path.
(Jessica chuckles)
And I went on the path that my mother set as an example
which was Studio 54 in Hollywood.
(Jessica laughs)
(audience laughs)
So, now I'm awake in this new arena,
and I love our lives.
I wouldn't trade them for a thing.
Reading this book, I was like, I wanna quit my job.
(Jessica laughs)
And this is the best book I've ever read
in the cookbook world, because it is a lifestyle.
It is a philosophy and a mentality
and we're gonna meet the authors of "Grand Dishes".
Please welcome Iska Lupton,
and Anastasia Miari.
(audience applauding)
Hi, Drew...
(clapping continues)
Hi, Anastasia.
(Jessica chuckles)
How are you?
(Anastasia mumbles)
We're good. We're good.
Yia yia just got very excited
'cause she saw you holding her book in your hand.
(all laughing)
I mean, that is your Yia yia
and she's right here on the cover.
Yeah.
Anastasia, how did the idea of this book come about?
Because it's so different than other cookbooks to me,
because it's beautiful recipes
but you transport us around the world,
and you give us wisdom beyond even the dishes.
Yeah, so it started because I was living in the UK
at the time, and I really just wanted a cook book
of my own Yia yia's recipes
because she cooks amazingly well.
And then I guess we did a shoot with Yia yia,
and Iska and our best friend, Ella,
and the photographs came back amazing.
So we put them on our Instagram account,
and then people started contacting us
about their own grandmothers.
So we decided to sort of go ahead and make it a global thing
and cook with grannies from all over the world.
Anastasia, do you have the same name as your Yia yia?
Yes, I do.
So (laughs) in Greece,
the grandchildren always get their grandparents names.
So you're always an ode to your own grandparents.
So, Anastasia, and Anastasia.
We both have the same name. (laughs)
In Latino culture,
a lot of mothers and daughters have the same name.
Really?
Mm-hmm. A lot of, yeah.
And then there are certain cultures
that men and their sons have the same name
which could be a lot--
It's more common place.
to live up to.
Yeah.
(both chuckling)
Yes. Exactly.
I love my grandmother's name. It's Deloris.
Wow. Yeah.
I thought about it.
I voted for it for my daughter, Frankie
'cause I was like, in short it's Dolly.
It's so cute, but she was a Frankie.
But I love the meaning behind this book.
And we're gonna take a quick commercial break,
and then we're going to come back,
and Iska, what are we gonna cook after the break?
We are making Yia yia's roasted vegetables,
which are actually on the cover of the book,
(Drew gasps)
and then Tzatziki to go with it,
which is a kind of garlicky yogurt dill.
I love to Tzatziki.
(bright upbeat music)